aggravé par tout ce qu'on lui doit
implémenter pour le même get
des fonds pour la poursuite de la production
nous nous arrêtons essentiellement nous sommes maintenant
produire le reste du carburant qui
nous étions avant la guerre à propos de nouveaux approvisionnements encore
non, et bien qu'ils ne soient pas encore établis, nous voici
sommes dans la phase d'attente, mais nous sommes en fait
dans le sud nous travaillons déjà
campagne de semis et nous voilà
face au problème que nous traversons
trois à cinq jours nous n'aurons rien pour travailler
nous n'avons pas de carburant et personne ne l'apportera ici
s'allume
Eh bien, nous pouvons envisager cette option
Mais
regarder la situation
aujourd'hui de toute façon nous grandissons
L'Ukraine grandit beaucoup plus
des produits
du volume dont elle a besoin pour
de notre propre production, nous sommes beaucoup
plus de nombre grandissent donc
sans exporter nous de toute façon
s'arrêter, c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y aura pas d'arrivée
la monnaie ne pourra pas payer
tout le monde